[Music]  so  [Music]  hi this is lindsey rose meta from sway  so shop and here are three ways to fight  fashion waste at home  number one loving your clothes make them  last we're  always taught to not have a sentimental  attachment to clothing but  we need to be more attached to the  things that we buy because those items  took  natural resources and labor to create  the longer you hold on to things  the less of an impact it's gonna have on  the environment number two mending  matters  every time you patch your clothes  instead of throwing them in the trash  that's gonna  extend the life of them and reduce the  impact on the planet  number three share your sustainability  story tell your friends and family what  you're up to  tell them about choosing youth recycling  remade upcycling  tell them that there are other options  besides buying brand new clothing  the only way that we're going to make  massive positive change on the planet is  by doing it together  [Music]  [Music]  you